if November means Thanksgiving in your
part of the world then you'll have some
cool free games to be thankful for this
month and if you're an Xbox Live Gold
member and want to know what you're
getting I've got you covered since we're
moving past October now you also won't
be seeing any scary games unless you're
afraid of high speed racing I guess
because first up on Xbox one is
TrackMania turbo this arcade racer
offers 200 tracks across a bunch of
different environments and if you
somehow don't find any you like the
robust track editor will let you create
something more your style TrackMania
turbo will be available all month long
if you prefer something a bit more story
driven on your Xbox one then you can
also check out tales from the
borderlands tell tales spinoff of the
gear box shooter looter keeps all the
wackiness of the borderlands series but
with dialogue choice driven gameplay
you'll get all five episodes when tales
from the borderlands becomes available
from October 16th through December 15 on
the 360 side you can chill out with
nights into dreams the 90s classic got
an HD re-release a few years back but it
kept all the high-flying gameplay of the
Sega Saturn original with all the dreams
and nightmares you may or may not
remember if you missed out on any of
nights into dreams earlier releases
you'll be able to take flight from
November 1st through the 15th and if
it's treasure you seek the 360 is also
getting deadfall adventures the Allan
Quatermain novels are the inspiration
for the Indiana Jones movies and this
action-adventure game just to give you
an idea of what to expect it'll be
available from November 16th through the
30th and thanks to backwards
compatibility both this and nights into
dreams can also be played on Xbox one
and those are your free games with gold
for November 2017 remember that you can
always check out gameplay clips and
reviews for these titles on GameSpot and
if you want to keep up with all of our
top stories
grab the official game spot now app on
iOS and Android
[Music]